this is a dispatch from High Command
regarding official tactics to be used in
the elimination of rebel scum all right
listen up all you freedom-loving
fighters of tyranny
we've got word from our spies inside the
Empire on some moves we can use to stick
it to the old marshmallow brigade the
following vehicle show is to be obeyed
as we annihilate those who oppose our
reign failure will not be tolerated yes
it's the vehicle show presented by
Duracell and today we're all about armed
conveniences from a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away when you first jump
into star wars battlefront you're gonna
go straight to the x-wing not only is it
written in your chromosomes not only
does it look hella cool but also the
x-wing training mission is the most
broadly applicable a-wings TIE fighters
tie interceptors all pretty much have
the same basic tactics so let's break
them down zoom in to acquire target as
soon as possible fire blasters and
bursts with short breaks in between so
that you don't over heat like a
Celestion gondolier when you have
missile lock your targets alarms are
going to be ringing and they'll probably
take evasive action wait until after
their action to fire and they're less
likely to be able to action away from
your action if you're on the flip side
and have a bogey on your tail use your
180 vasive maneuver to shake them
rolling won't do much against the
missile and it might just roll you into
a research station or whatever these
buildings out in the middle of nowhere
are if you don't have the 180 charged
you can do the manual version by ducking
the throttle turning sharply and then
revving back up to full speed remember
missile lock and incoming missile are
two different stages of danger wait
until incoming missile to use your
faction specific ability popping a
shield for the rebels and cheesing it
skyward for the Imperials now if you're
taking on land targets there's really
only one cardinal rule don't fly into
the freaking ground the ground is not
your home the sky is your home ground
bad sky good are you picking up on my
patronizing tone well that's because so
many dummies smash their planes into the
obviously bad
ground that the point seems worth
belaboring though to be fair to the
dummies
it does look friggin cool when a giant
spaceship rockets into the ground and
explodes protect your future by using
the time-tested sure fire safety method
of pulling out of your dives too late
long angled approach vectors are key to
taking out your primary ground targets
stationary turrets and ATS T's but only
cue up a strafing run once you know the
skies are clear or you're gonna be an
easy target and if you see the enemy
infantry all clustered in one area he'll
take a run at them too you don't really
have to bull's-eye those womp rats
thanks to the splash damage on your
blasters and if you really want to make
a splash if you want to be the vehicular
hero or villain you've always dreamed of
being then fire up fighter squadron mode
and skim the ground for that golden
ticket Millennium Falcon or slave 1 it
doesn't matter if you're in Yolo Fett or
Han swallows ride you are the heaviest
hitter on the block like literally if
you run into any regular ship you can
just watch them break over your hull
like so many champagne bottles but while
ice breaking your way through the skies
may be delightful always keep in mind
your main priority is the transports you
either destroy them because you can do
it so so quickly or defend them by
hanging a little ways back from them and
just swatting anybody that comes into
range and prolong your life by playing
To Your Strengths the Millennium Falcon
is more nimble so use your regular speed
boost and tight turning evasion tactics
along with judiciously timed shields
slave 1 is slower to turn so be sure to
activate the radar disrupter as often as
you can and if you're not the one flying
the hero ship just hang back from it and
pick off all the wannabes that fly in
and try to take it down it's that
celebrity worship man then poison in
people's minds since like Old Republic
times it's no good pop quiz hotshot do
you know what a snow speeder is times up
here are moving pictures of one
you know actually I feel like shouting
is the wrong way to intro a snowspeeder
like okay the thing can fly but compared
to members of the wing Thai clan it
feels a little sluggish maybe the name
speeder is just like aspirational let's
just all agree that it's more of a
scooter the snow scooter it can't go
very high and so it can't evade very
well which makes it very vulnerable to
all the high flyers on the map but can
do one very special thing and that's
hog-tie in 80 80 this is the Hail Mary
play of Star Wars Battlefront you don't
want to rely on it
but you should still practice it in the
training mission and keep it in your
snow scooter skill set outside of that
focus your attacks on squashing turrets
and popping a tsts like so many Andorian
logs and if right now you're thinking
technically it should be forest moon of
Endor e'en log then I've got a wiki on
midi-chlorians that I just love for you
to read ah if all this flying is a
little too flighty then maybe some
ground flying is more your speed her
bikes these things go fast like too fast
maybe they really should be deployed
somewhere else besides a giant frickin
forest everything that the long
straightaways of speeder bike training
are pretty awesome but the multiplayer
maps are just smaller and harder to
maneuver on so you're really more of a
distraction than a threat try switching
to first-person view to make it a little
easier to line up targets and also just
to live a little you know cuz life is
short
especially on a speeder bike
when even hovering over the ground makes
you groan like a Wookiee after a long
night in Mos Eisley it's best to try to
stand on your own two feet your own two
Robo stompy feet of doom that is the 80s
t is like a mini hero character that the
Empire can use in a lot of situations
and it packs a mean punch if you
regularly use your grenade barrage and
rocket abilities hit them every time the
cooldown is over don't let those poor
little projectiles languish it's not
fair to them they want to be killing
prioritize threats to you like
environmental turrets and watch out for
those nasty little anti-vehicle turrets
that infantry enemies can deploy you'll
be targeted from the skies as well but
if you fire your rocket at a ship and
loosely track your target with your
reticle the mild homing tendencies of
your projectile make you a pretty decent
anti-air platform which is what the a
TST is a platform your natural tendency
will be to treat it more like a soldier
because of the controls but if the a TST
was a soldier
it would have crippling arthritis and be
drunk better to think of yourself as a
minimally mobile turret tower and play
it conservatively working your weapons
from far after all if history teaches us
anything it's that a tsts charging
headlong into combat get killed by teddy
bears
this ain't Toy Story 3 man the teddy
bears are gonna win well that about
rounds it out for this episode of the
vehicle show wait it's ok we forgot
someone alright yeah lumber on over here
you big galoot
behold the 8080 technically a vehicle
you can use in battlefront though your
usage is governed by a timer unlike
every vehicle else your options are
pretty limited here you've got two
blaster types that you can switch
between as the situation dictates then
there's the orbital strike good for
clearing out active uplink stations or
disrupting popular pathways from spawn
points your job is just to shoot as much
as possible and use your orbital strike
as much as possible and then keep
shooting some more until your rental
period is up and you have to turn in
your keys it's the people trying to take
down the 8080 that get all the good
strats ex and or a wings should zoom
high above the Walker and then slowly
fly down towards it blasting all the way
snow scooters
hide near the corners of the map until
the time is right to throw the Hail Mary
bless their little low-flying hearts
infantry should throw down those
anti-vehicle turrets with a sight line
to the 8080 and take advantage of their
substantial range or seek out turrets to
unload with for as long as you aren't
exploded every other rebel should keep
an eye on heavy hand in their card
loadout for just such an occasion
it never doesn't not hurt to be always
forever prepared in the ongoing battle
between donut heads and shy guys those
who can master the wing attend legged
vehicles will have a distinct advantage
with this video training course under
your belt you're ready to get out there
and engage in the true challenge of Star
Wars battlefronts racing against your
teammates to pick up floating blue ghost
coins haha
the ghost coin is mine
that's it you got it
you
you